- Good afternoon, so I'm Jacob
Kim and I'm the webmaster
at the Hirshhorn Museum
and Sculpture Garden.
And I primarily work with
web and digital projects
that interface with on the
public engagement side of things.
Dan Michaelson is our,
do you want to introduce yourself?
- I'm an adjunct faculty in
the Graphic Design department
at the school of art.
I teach a couple of the
interaction design classes
to the grad students there.
But I also run a digital
studio in New York City
as my full-time job.
And that's how I got
connected with the Hirshhorn.
- Right and Dan was our creative
lead and development lead
on the Hirshhorn Eye project.
And I'll talk a little bit
about the steps that we took
up to developing this
digital engagement project
and then Dan can go into
a little bit more detail.
So the Hirshhorn Museum is
Smithsonian's national museum
of modern and contemporary art.
And our use case for machine vision was
to create a digital engagement product
to be used in our galleries.
One of the benefits of being
a contemporary art museum is
that we have access to living artists.
A lot of the artworks that
we exhibit in our galleries,
the artists are still around today.
So we wanted to take this
advantage and leverage it
in a way where we can share their stories
and create more context for the artworks
that are being exhibited at the Hirshhorn.
When we started exploring
different engagement products
out there already in
existence and technologies,
we were looking for something
that could help deliver
that point of view from
the living artists.
And we started looking at a wide variety
of different technologies
and products out in existence
to help facilitate this vision.
We looked at technology
such as VR, AR products,
in-gallery interactives,
native apps, and such.
All of these tech products
have very strong merits of their own,
but they weren't exactly
what we were looking for.
A lot of them were cumbersome,
they took a lot of bit of foot space
inside the museum galleries.
And we wanted something
that would be a little bit more invisible.
So with our market research,
we finally arrived on a
vision for a product that we
wanted to develop on our own.
And to help part of the
vision for that product
that we wanted to develop
was to create a connection
between the visitor, the living
artists, and the artworks
that are presented in our
galleries, and tell their stories.
We started with an old model
of the traditional audio
guides that are available,
and we wanted to use emergent technologies
to create the next generation
of audio-guided museum
guide for our space.
And when we started that
process we started looking
at technologies such as QR codes,
location-based technologies, beacons.
But all of that felt very cumbersome
and not very user-friendly
for our visiting public.
Ultimately we settled
on leveraging image-recognition technology
to create a product where a
user could go to a website,
point their phone at
artworks, and listen directly
from the artist talking
about their practice.
So in partnership with Linked by Air
and Antenna International,
we developed this product
called the Hirshhorn Eye.
The Hirshhorn Eye is a
web-based museum guide.
It uses computer vision
to recognize the artworks
in our galleries and deliver content.
And I'd like to show you a
little video about how it works.
- [Dan] It just takes
a minute to start once.
- There we go. (soft music playing)
- Welcome to my artwork in
the lobby of the Hirshhorn.
- So I thought I'd talk a little bit
about the process that let
this project come together.
And maybe it's nice to end or conclude
this amazing set of talks
with some snapshots in a way,
of a team trying to apply
the kind of research
that you guys are doing
and that everyone here is
doing in different ways.
One thing that we realized early on is
that thinking cross-functionally
and in an interdisciplinary
way is really essential.
And so I'll start with the thank yous,
rather than end with them.
The project was a collaboration
between actually a pretty
wide group of stakeholders
within the Hirshhorn museum,
from the director, to curators,
to exhibition designers,
and Jacob, and visitor experience
people, as well as the CIO
on technical infrastructure,
issues that arose,
Antenna International, which
helped with production,
really great team of filmmakers
in New York called Captain and the Fox,
a user testing specialist, a marketer.
The image recognition itself is
the easy part in this project.
It's an API service from a
company based in Barcelona.
And to Catherine's point,
the actual image recognition,
at least in a project
like this, is a commodity.
Basically we're a small business
and the technical challenges,
per se, were not large for us.
We didn't need to be an Amazon.
And similarly, my students in
the art school are doing lots
of stuff around computer
vision, image recognition now.
So there are, this kind of
work is definitely percolating
into the creative atmosphere for sure.
And I think that that's
really leading lots
of really interesting opportunities.
Our role was the user
experience of the product
and really thinking that
through holistically,
the interface design,
what does it look like
and how does it actually
work on the screen,
and the engineering other than
the actual image recognition
neural network itself.
Also really involved were the artists
who you saw, Olafur Eliasson starting
to tell a story about his work.
But the key to this was
not, it's not interesting
to tell the user what is
the title of the work.
The purpose of this is to connect the user
to an artist talking about the work,
so what stories they're telling,
is like 90% of the product.
And also, as I'll talk
about, we learned a lot
from what we would typically call users,
but a museum would tend to call visitors,
the people who are actually using
this product in this space.
So today Rebecca really, at the
very beginning this morning,
talked about or evoked a large team
in big science working together.
And in a humanities project like this one,
an interdisciplinary team
is also really important.
Especially for a project that takes images
in the physical environment as its input
and basically it's images in, images out.
You get other moving images as the output
and you're transforming
pixels into pixels.
So thinking synthetically
about user experience,
technology, visitors, artists, curation,
what are the sequence of works
that are being brought together?
Content production, staff maintainers,
how are people at the Hirshhorn
authoring these stories
and continuing to expand and change them
as new exhibitions are mounted?
And also how are visitor experienced staff
on the floor helping visitors use this?
And also the physical environment,
which I'll talk a lot about,
or talk more about in a minute.
Thinking synthetically and
holistically about all of that,
even when those are the domains
of multiple different vendors,
multiple different departments,
multiple kinds of thinking,
that's really important for success.
Here's an early snapshot
of a team of Hirshhorn's
and Smithsonian staff
and also that's Alice
from Antenna brainstorming and testing.
Lots of this project was
scanning simulations of images
in small offices and figuring
what that would be like.
I think this was one of the
first web-based applications
of its kind in this space.
And this is possible, or
that is the case because,
as of 2017 when it was only
with iOS 11 was it possible
to scan an image in real
time in a web browser.
So iOS 11 came out in the fall of 2017,
right around the time that this
product was meant to launch.
So we were developing towards
a thing that didn't yet exist.
And we really didn't want to
launch this as a native app,
because we know from
research that the take-up
of native apps in a museum
like this is really low.
People don't want to install
an app on their device
that they're only gonna
use once or not often.
So that involves a sort of
embrace of risk a little bit
on everybody's part to think
about developing for something
that hopefully was gonna work
six months down the road.
And we managed that by having fallbacks.
We had a certain native app fallback
that we could use if necessary.
Peter talked about, or
mentioned, how to work with,
rather than against, human
curation and expert description.
And I think that was
really key to our thinking
that it's not the
technology that's the end,
but the technology is just an instrument
for story-telling and for connecting users
to living artists telling their stories.
User testing was a huge
part of our project.
And we did that with Hirshhorn staff,
we did it with Smithsonian
staff at one point,
like hundreds of Smithsonian staff.
We did it occasionally with
random visitors on the floor.
And very importantly, we
did it by recruiting testers
on Facebook and places like
that in order to ensure
that we had a diverse
demographics among our testers.
The big goal of the project
was to show diverse artists
actually from of all genders,
nationalities, ethnicities,
and similarly a goal was
to make contemporary art,
which can be alienating and
intimidating, feel accessible
to lots of different kinds of visitors.
Meaning tourists off the
mall who were not art experts
and also people of all ages
and cultural backgrounds.
So testing with lots of different kinds
of visitors was essential and we learned
so much from doing that.
And I'll talk about some of the,
I'll give a couple examples
of what we learned.
Testing at the Hirshhorn
goes outside as well.
It is also a sculpture garden.
Here are non-staff testers.
And even seeing how people
physically bodily use
this product or how do they stand,
how much are they looking at artwork,
how much are they looking at
their phone is really helpful.
Both quantitatively, like
sometimes it's something we needed
to address or remediate, like
when people were not using
the thing in a way that was gonna work
or would interfere with their enjoyment.
But also qualitatively, just understanding
that different people are gonna use
this interface in different ways.
One thing we learned pretty quickly,
not so much from user
testing but from looking
at other similar applications
is that lots of people
would be confused and think
that you can use this website
when you're not at the Hirshhorn Museum.
And so we thought should
we use location permission?
But that can be kind of intrusive.
And I think the team kind of
finally collaboratively came up
with this really basic,
this is the dumbest thing
you've seen all day.
We'll just ask people
and that's actually been,
I think a really effective solution
and something that's really,
we design lots of websites for museums
and this simple way of thinking
has actually really been
influencing how I think
about other museum websites as well.
Early designs, when you
could sort of keep scanning.
So you could almost collect artworks.
And because the scanner
is so sensitive in a way
and artworks can be hung close together,
the idea was that we wouldn't wanna,
you could be confused
by accidentally having
the wrong thing triggered.
You're trying to scan one thing,
but there's another
thing right next to it.
And so we thought even while
you're watching one artist talk
to you it might keep
scanning and then collect
up in this tray at the top.
And that's the prototype
that we tested with users
and we quickly found
that that was confusing.
And we needed to take this
already simple interface
and simplify it even further
and remove that feature.
Sort of physical surprise that we saw was
that visitors really wanna scan the label.
They're so trained to be
scanning like a QR code,
and also to be searching for a label,
that they would walk up to the label
and get really close to it and scan it
and then step back and
look at the artwork.
And what our goal was that
you wouldn't need to be so
didactic in your use of it.
But that it could be a
kind of freer experience
of walking around and just kind
of breezing your phone around
and things would pop up.
And we knew from testing with our visitors
that no one will read the instruction.
And that's not a judgment,
that's just for sure.
I wouldn't either, you're
trying to get to it,
get to the experience.
And so we tried this
illustration that could model
the behavior that we were
hoping for visitors to take.
Even so, it was so fascinating
walking around with visitors
and talking to them about
their experience using this.
And a lot of them talked to us
about their consciousness
of wanting to look up
at the work and not get too
absorbed in their phone.
Some visitors just hate it
and they absolutely don't
wanna use an electronic device
when they're in a museum.
Other, some kinds of young
people they just wanna,
they walk through, they
scan absolutely everything,
they watch the first three
seconds of every video.
And other people really had
a transformative experience
with it and talked about seeing artists
who looked like them.
Understanding for the first
time that a contemporary art
that might be ugly to them,
understanding the motivations
of an artist and where it
comes from really deepened
their connection to it in a way
that sometimes they hadn't had before.
But this whole genre of our...
This product is used in
real life and I would argue
that that's true of
everything on some level,
of everything that was talked about today,
that there's a physical context
in which people are reading
books, or doing data entry,
or learning about art,
or engaging with art.
And that physical disposition
was a big influence
on the design of the interface as well as
on solving some of the kinds of problems
that I've just alluded to.
So early on when we were
doing testing it was important
to also include the labels
and think about the context
that this is happening in.
This is not a sort of
disembodied codex of jpgs.
For the sort of fallbacks,
so that a user who,
the image recognition does not
work very well on label text,
it's not distinct enough and so,
but it was really important
that there be a fallback
for someone who would scan the label.
We learned that from watching visitors
and also because some of these works,
which I'll talk about in a minute,
are very hard to recognize.
And so in those cases, well
in every case basically,
there's an image, a frame
of the video that you get,
for example, which is
reliably recognizable.
And which also cues the
user that cues the visitor,
that this work is in the system.
And one of the nice things
about having such a low barrier
to entry that is not a
native application is
that there is this short
url that you can just enter
into your web browser at any time
so that you can start anywhere
in the system and follow any pathway.
But basically every work in
the museum is in the system
with a few exceptions at this point.
And finally, letting visitors
know that this is here
and that there is this
additional available layer
to the experiences is really sort of one
of the biggest challenges.
And it's even more heightened actually
at the Smithsonian museums on the mall
where there's no pay gate,
there's no ticketing.
So you really just walk
right into the museum.
So there's no point at which,
there's no inherent point
at which a visitor services staff can say,
"Here is this thing that you can do."
So on the one hand, there's
this low barrier to entry.
On the other hand, we really need people
to know that they can take that step.
The exhibition that we launched with,
ironically was called what
absence is made out of.
And an image recognition
app is about the pixels.
It's a kind of a Ghost in the Shell.
It is about dematerialized objects.
So what absence is made of
was a very poetic
exhibition to start with.
It featured not exclusively
minimalist and conceptual art,
but a lot of minimalist
and conceptual art.
Reading from the description
of the exhibition,
a curator described it
as the spaces left behind
when something disappears
and as I work on a massive scale,
yet with the barest materials.
And so this is Didier
Vermeiren's sculpture.
It's meant, in part,
to look like the pedestal
for other artwork.
That's Fred Sandback, it's string.
That's Reynier Novo's black squares.
And these are Joseph Beuys' black squares.
And it turns out that once
you've seen even one black square
into your image recognition database,
every dark corner of the museum
now pops up Joseph Beuys.
So Peter kind of talked
about an unexpected,
that Fred Wilson image and talk
about unexpected juxtapositions,
and really created a
situation in which work
that was meant to be curated together
and tell a really amazing
story in fact matched up
with each other through
this technological prism
in a way that was a challenge
as well as an opportunity.
That's Giovanni Anselmo.
This hand is not part of the artwork.
The artwork is just a single
slide in a slide projector
with the word visible
projecting into empty space.
And so you can only see it
when you interrupt the projection.
And it's also a single slide,
so it just slowly burns
actually in the light.
As it changes it get more
and more brown every day>
so this is an artwork that is
meant to defy machine vision.
But we can work around this problems often
by seeding the scene.
And by, as a couple of
people have talked about,
by making sure that there
we're including humans
in this process of thinking about
where the artwork is located,
literally in this case.
And taking a couple steps back
or moving around the
sculpture to see images
that are gonna be effective.
And that means again watching visitors
and doing lots of testing.
And I think that's a kind of,
like Steven was talking about,
a kind of human knowledge
that it is always going
to be an essential part of
these projects especially.
And will be most effective when you work
in an interdisciplinary way.
So the last thing was I
wanted to show is the solution
to the Anselmo problem and
critics gotta talk about
in a work like that, is it
the artwork, the projection,
is it the situation, is
it the slide projector.
In our case, it's the slide projector
that scans actually really effectively.
So here's that work shining back out
and this is a team of
testers from the Hirshhorn
and the broader Smithsonian, kinda' trying
to figure this stuff out.
So I'll stop there, thanks a lot.
(audience clapping)
- And I just wanted to add that,
going into the next section
of the talk is that,
while the Hirshhorn Eye was driven
with a very specific content
strategy at the Hirshhorn.
We believe that what we
created is applicable widely
across different subject matter.
So what we've done at the Smithsonian is
that we've started
taking the Hirshhorn Eye
and adapting it for use
across our different museums.
And we're also working
with third-party external organizations
and trying to adapt the Hirshhorn
Eye for their use as well.
Eventually what we hope to do is
to create a open source
version of the Hirshhorn Eye
and to make it readily
available for smaller museums
and organizations to pick it up
and deploy it at their space, as well.
Thank you.
- [Man] Thanks.
(audience clapping)
(soft music playing)